l'airbus a380 devait décoller à 10h30 il
est parti à 10h29 un sans-faute applaudi
jusqu'au conseil des ministres patrice
pollet et rémy poissonnier ils sont des
milliers en bord de piste tous sortis de
leurs ateliers ou de leur bureau pour
assister au décollage de celui qu'il
considère un peu comme leurs enfants
l'a380 il est 10 heures 29 précise quand
le géant lance à fond ses quatre moteurs
rolls royce et s'élance sur la piste un
roulage parfait rectiligne et à la
surprise générale il décolle très courts
et sans faire beaucoup de bruit
une montée vers le ciel parfaite
qui a surpris l'ensemble des employés
travaillent à un indien ce magnifique à
la possibilité qu'elle est là du collège
as l'impression que tu n'étais même pas
au maximum deux des moteurs superbe pas
de bruit une tranquille c'est vrai
qu'ils étaient superbes ce matin y
compris à l'instant où elle bascule sur
l'ailé gauche pour prendre son premier
virage un vol que le pdg des russes
apprécié en spécialiste d'abord j'ai
fait des observations un peu technique
10 ont constaté que l'avion était
extrêmement stable voyez aucune
vibration nulle part également qu'il
était incroyablement silencieux
on avait beaucoup travaillé pour ça mais
c'est bon de l'entendre bon puis ensuite
comme l'avion commençait à monter
j'étais très ému voilà pour le moment
l'avion est toujours en vol l'équipage
en ce moment procède aux premières
validation retour sur l'aéroport de
toulouse blagnac aux environs de 14h30